[Music]
are you guys doing today doing great um
before we get started I just want to say
the only reason that Collider gets to be
at the Toronto Film Festival is because
of our great sponsors so I want to give
a huge thank you to Nordstrom Canada for
being a great sponsor and helping us be
here and a huge thank you to Nordstrom
Canada now I get to talk to you guys
everyone has to pay the bills I feel
that yeah you know um so I guess jumping
right on in from the footage I've seen
from the movie it looks incredible it
looks like such a powerful film talk a
little about what it was like being
basically making this well you just you
know as an actor you take on the level
of importance that this film represents
you know talking about just all the
injustice is that they're gone every day
you know every day people are wrongfully
accused and thrown into serious
situations you know wrongfully so and I
feel that this this movie is gonna plant
the seed a little bit get people's gears
turning around a topic that they
probably don't pay attention to every
day and that's the first step you know
in the film Bryan Stevenson takes
gradual small you know baby steps in
order to show progress and I feel like
us as a society we need to start doing
that and it's up to pieces of art like
just mercy to get that going good answer
yeah I think I'm being a part of
something that I believe is going to
help change the consciousness of America
I think that you know we're talking
about a subject of incarceration of
service but I feel like as a country
maybe even as a world but as a country I
feel like our humanity is on trial it's
interesting how we discard certain
sectors of people when it's not
comfortable when it doesn't fit into our
idea of what a human being should be or
should be able to do so it'll be
interesting I think to have this
conversation in a way that forces us to
re-engage it forces us to look at people
who are not like us
and still see the us in them and
hopefully that will help us to to move
forward in a very different and more
meaningful way one of the things that I
think is so important about this movie
is that more and more I feel like people
are going to the movies just for
escapist fare and I think that films
like this need to be made to remind us
of what movies can do and what movies
can say and address that maybe other
things can't you know maybe if you could
sort of touch on that and why you guys
want it to be a part of it well you know
I love that if if you feel uncomfortable
about the topic that we're speaking on
in our film then you know it says
something it says that there's a piece
of you that wishes it wasn't that way
you know and you got to be uncomfortable
if you go and grow all growth has a
little bit of uncomfortableness to it so
I I welcome that villain and this movie
tells the story that tells many stories
but that the protagonist of the film is
Brian Stevenson who is a generational
doer meaning that a person comes along
once a generation who makes so much of a
difference is so unbelievably impactful
that they truly can be called unique
Aristotle said it's not what we think
it's what we do our lives are composed
of our actions and Bryan Stevenson
Michael B Jordan plays him in the film
is such a figure in terms of bringing
justice to the American justice system
I'm gonna pass the mic to Rob I mean one
I am very appreciative to Warner
Brothers for being bold enough to take
on this project and put it out there for
us to have these kinds of conversations
I'm thankful to be a part of it with
these phenomenal artists and giving
voice to the voiceless in a lot of
situations where
they're not being considered or not
being respected are not getting that
level of humanity that they should get
and when we have a system that is
designed to protect the rich and guilty
but condemn the poor and innocent we
really need to step back and critically
think about that and have conversation
and hopefully we can move towards a
place of healing for everybody you know
sure I'm for all four of you I'm
assuming you guys read a lot of scripts
and you're always you know I'm just
curious when you read something like
this for the first time what's your
takeaway from it and how quickly were
you like f I need to be a part of this
you get excited because you know as
actors we want material we can chew on
that can really motivate us and and and
get us in those spaces so that we can
bring these characters to life within
our own experiences so yeah when we get
these kinds of scripts it's amazing and
I'm a pastor's might back the ten
they're passing the mic something that
was so special to me was seeing in many
Macmillan women that I have known for
years women that I have watched stand in
the gap for families for their own
family for themselves so it was
wonderful to be able to serve and kind
of amplify a life that we don't always
see I think that with regard to Bryan
Stevenson with every page in reading the
book and the script it's like how does
he do this the work that he does is
tremendous and it forced me to think you
know no one can do everything I think
he's kind of close
no one can do everything but everyone
can do something so what's my something
you know what do i do from here what do
we all do from here I guess for me I
want to play characters at this point
who are irresistible and that doesn't
mean they're necessarily decent people
but it's it's it's about exploration
inside of my
in service of something greater a
greater story and it was certainly an
irresistible character but more
importantly it was irresistible to be a
part of this project Bryan Stevenson
who has devoted his life to the pursuit
of justice particularly for African
Americans in our justice system in the
United States but actually for anyone I
think he's somewhat colorblind even
though a great deal of just by virtue of
the fact that so many of the wrongly
condemned in the United States happened
to be people in black and brown bodies
but I don't think that actually makes a
tremendous amount of difference to him I
think he wants to exonerate the wrongly
accused and being a part of telling that
story I would have done a day on this
movie and I think that's probably true
for all of us
luckily we each of us got really
wonderful parts oh let me flip the
question because I've 99% of the people
that are gonna watch this will not
actually know who you play in the movie
and I hate asking the generic question
but could each of you talk a little bit
about who you play in the movie I play
Anthony ray Hinton
he he was wrongfully accused of a murder
and was sent to death row in Alabama for
30 years now I play you know it's a
group of us on the row you know and you
know my part isn't you know I'm not it's
about watching Macmillan and Brian
Stevenson but Anthony serves as a relief
to his fellow inmates in their members
of the road because we know that this
isn't the life that was really set out
for us and this is a bump that we go and
get through together and it's uh yeah
it's a powerful role I'm so happy to be
a part of a film like this and you know
I hope I do Anthony ray Hinton pro I
play
character we all play real-life
characters I play a character named
Ralph Myers who bears faults who bears
false witness implicating Walter
McMillian in a capital crime and I over
the course of the film need to face the
ramifications of that I play Minnie
McMillan who is the wife of the wrongly
accused Walter McMillian and many I
believe in this story is an interesting
look into how not just the person who
was actually incarcerated is affected
but how their incarceration effects
affects an entire family and entire
community and I think one thing that's
really interesting about her is she has
every reason to walk away but she
chooses still to stand I play Herbert
Richardson young man who hasn't even
kissed the girl gets shipped off to war
survives the war see his whole platoon
gets blown up come back to the state
with no type of support falls in love
with a girl
finally and his only way of
communicating love and affection to this
girl is through what he's learned from
war and now he's in a situation that
he's on death row and we'll see what
happens to him you know I don't want to
spoil it but yeah so that's who I play
when you are playing real people it adds
that dimension to the to the role where
you have to take what's on the script
but also try to basically it's a tough
thing to do you're trying to be
realistic you're also making a movie
it's one of these things to talk a
little bit about like was there one
piece of research or film or something
that you latched onto to sort of get an
A into your character I had a picture
like my character what is is not with us
anymore so really I just had a picture
to draw from and then it was just
like my own personal experiences the
people that send my life the honor that
I in respect I wanted to deliver on this
man's voice of having the responsibility
to play it so I pretty much drew from
from those things in that that picture
to pictures for me yeah there was a
there was picture and video for Minnie
McMillan but then there was also I'm
from the South I'm from Georgia there
was something in seeing her in hearing
her voice and in connect and connecting
to the fact that it was just a little
over 30 years ago so this is not some
ancient time far far away so this woman
is my community of women of church
ladies of aunties of women that raised
me and me watching how they stood in the
gap so I had video fairly extensive
interview footage and it was a
challenging character he's pretty
extreme the character I play and the
that the trick was for me not to do it
in a way that ever contradicted the
movie or it's a character that can be
that can stand out and he shouldn't in
this movie in a sense and so it was an
interesting balance just to try to bring
a level of I don't know humility to an
extreme performance because he's a he's
a a burn victim and he's got somewhat
deformed aspect to him and and to find a
way to play that in service of the
greater whole which is this film in
which he's not the main character it's
really about Walter McMillian and Bryan
Stevenson and I think it's it's great
for us to be this supporting
Samba around around those two characters
and yeah with Anthony just watching him
speak about being on death row for 30
years you know and I watched him speak
on on videos I found on the internet you
know my man got his Oprah visit when he
got out so he was killing it
it's just a good redemption story and I
was so happy for him and I just couldn't
put into my imagination what he had to
go through for 30 years you know I'm 28
I haven't even got there yet you know so
I just have 30 years of your life just
gone you know your mother having to pass
without you being there and talking
about how much he loved his mother and I
just wanted to I just felt like somebody
should do something for him you know and
I'm glad I got to to be that you know I
hope he loves how he's represented I
felt a piece of me in Anthony hearing
him speak also he doesn't like the
Boston Red Sox and I don't like them
either and so you know that's a good
bear I do root for the Red Sox and this
is why we'll never get along never see
that go Lakers right anyway listen I
really mean and I the footage I've seen
is so so tremendous I cannot wait to see
the finished movie Congrats on being
part of the Toronto International Film
Festival and I hope it's a huge
I hope so many people see it and take
away something from the experience thank
you on that note thank you so much for
coming in thanks for having us